просто витрачаєте дурно кошти платників
податків всі не люблять депутатів
викинути все опзж з Верховної Ради я
розберуся сам якось Всіх вітаю
підписуйтеся на наш YouTube канал тут
правда про роботу Верховної Ради України
давайте не керуйте Ще раз Кажу як ви
знаєте на телеканал Рада щороку іде 170
млн грн а це на хвилинку 5 000 Дронів
fpv які точно підійшли для фронту для
наших захи
І от нещодавно журналісти з'ясували що 2
третини цих колосальних сум ідуть на
таку близьку до офіса президента
компанію kкінокіт ці гроші виділені
фірмі кінокіт яка належить людям
із орбіти офісу президента України не
перші Зеленський такі робить так робили
при кучмі так робили при Януковичі і за
роки війни 250 млн уже пішли на цей
кінокід тільки від ради на розробку
концепції а тендер як провели все це я
дивився в на сайті
prozoro там Скажімо так умови конкурсу
для конкурсу виставлені пізніше ніж
угода із переможцем 250 млн за два роки
війни на
розробку якогось там контенту Та в нас
Олексій Гончаренко безкоштов
розробив контент і в тіктокі показує
трансляції Верховної Ради розумієте А ви
просто витрачаєте дурно кошти платників
податків Ну а концепція ради Ось така що
бачимо да порожня зала ніхто парламент
не показує і На жаль ви Дорогі українці
навіть не знаєте що тут голосується це
неправильно більшість українців хочуть
бачити як засідає рада тому що на вас
вішають всіх собак всі не люблять
депутатів і дуже важливо щоби такі
чутливі закони як закон про мобілізацію
як закон про електронний реєстр
обговорювався публічно ми звертаємося до
голови профільного комітету з питань
свободи слова з наступним колеги
потрібно повертати журналістів в сесійну
залу потрібно повернати трансляцію
включати виключені телеканали марафон
треба навпаки припиняти отже дуже
важливі голосування законопроект
162пе дарність наполягала на
автоматичному статусі ОБД і саме так як
компроміс народився законопроект 162
який окрім УД яке виписано там не
ідеально має ще і норми щодо єдиного
електронного реєстру
військовозобов'язаних і ми наполягали на
тому що якщо людина в районі бойових дій
на першій лінії фронту виконує бойові
розпорядження які підписує командир
Значить вона повинна автоматично
отримувати статус учасника бойових дій а
не ходити з цими довідками
бюрократичними збирати їх Ну і тягнеться
це все руками в нас колосальна проблема
в державі наші військові не можуть
отримати статус убд деякі які по року
два роки на нулі служать а отримати
статус учасника бойових дій не можуть Що
таке Єдиний електронний реєстр
військовозобов'язаних Ну він існує в
усіх країнах ЄС і НАТО це реєстр де є
іфо ція про тих громадян які є
військовозобов'язаними і звичайно такий
реєстр військовозобов'язаних потрібен і
в Україні але на жаль до другого читання
цей законопроект було спотворено через
поправки про надмірне втручання в
особисте життя українців ви створюєте
реєстр чи вводите цифрову диктатуру в
державі наприклад туди намагалися внести
поправки про те що обробляється
інформація про всіх членів родини навіть
без їх згоди ну це буде Big Brother
Watch Большой Брат за тобою спостерігає
Ну це треба зупиняти не треба робити
такі закони мета яких незрозуміла це вже
не для того щоб полегшити облік
військовозобов'язаних це для того щоб
знати про людину все цей реєстр
військовозобов'язаних буде прив'язаний
до єдиного виборчого реєстру виглядає
так що весь цей Реєстр і всі ці дані
персональні тут надмірний збір цих даних
хочуть зібрати для цілей в тому числі
виборчих в тому числі щоб отримати дані
про людину знати все для того щоб далі
можливо було наприклад впливати на
результати голосування і тут теж є До
речі проблема адже після початку
повномасштабного вторгнення єдиний
реєстр виборців було фактично закрито
і знищено і скільки там часу сьогодні
потрібно на його відновлення незрозуміло
також там є наприклад такі норми що
коженце да вець повинен створити такий
реєстр військовозобов'язаних і сам там
вносити якісь дані наші нещасні ці
підприємці які ще жеврюють якось мало
того що їх тут штурмують і влаштували
гітьманщину проти них мало того що
закручують гайки податки хабарі давайте
ще їх зобов'язжемо мати ці електронні
кабінети окремо вести на кожного ну це
Друзі Ну це зайва вся абсолютна історія
і що тривожило щеце
захист захист цього реєстру щодня
Україна зазначає значних кібератак
останній випадок який ми з вами побачили
Це була компанія Київстар ми знаємо От
коли почалося повномасштабне вторгнення
скільки окупанти приходили з готовими
списками в яких були патріоти учасники
АТО ос проукраїнські громадяни і просто
по цим спискам вбивали і знищували Такі
дані на сьогодні представляють
найбільший інтерес для нашого ворога це
персональні дані наших
військових персональні дані наших
військових які подаються в електронний
реєстр у всеобсяжному обсязі тому для
нас було дуже важливо отримати чітку
інформацію про захист цих персональних
даних хто є володареми реєстра а
власником його буде Міністерство оборони
з генеральним штабом і як він буде за
захищений давайте послухаємо тих хто
дійсно воює наприклад пана Костенка
Романа що не можна зберігати дані про
наших захисників за кордоном і нічого не
говориться про те щоб ці дані після
війни повернути назад І власне Служба
безпеки України так само тут
висловлювала свої зауваження що от
вперше в цьому законопроекті
закладається хмарні послуги коли реєстри
будуть зберігатися не в Україні а на
хмарах там наших країнпартнерів це буде
тривати і після закінчення воєнного
стану опозиції вдалося збити кілька ну
найбільш таких одіозних поправок які
стосувалися захисту персональних
данихлена друзі Зелена за 223 рішення не
прийнято Дякую колеги хоч щось ми збили
але в законі залишилося багато норм які
є суперечливими це не лише про убд це не
лише про реєстр військовозобов'язаних
Там є багато норм які є контраверсійними
10 років тому в цій залі 16 січня
приймалися диктаторські закони закони
Януковича які порушували Конституцію і
забирали права у наших
співгромадян сьогодні законопроект 1062
дуже наближений до нього і цікаво що
самі слуги дали за цей законопроект 190
голосів як завжди на допомогу їм при
голосуванні прийшли опзж і групи Ну і
так от разом назбирали 249 голосів за
все це витягується голосами тих кого
давно треба було викинути з Верховної
Ради України Постанова про те щоб
викинути все опзж з Верховної Ради
давним-давно лежить спікера вже більше
року я не знаю ну це це це говорить про
все от реальнона сьогодні коаліція якою
вона є в Верховній Раді України депутати
кілька разів намагалися нагадати голові
Верховної Ради що є рішення і
регламентного комітету і комітету з
нацбезпеки про відкликання маріяни
безуглої посади заступниці голови
комітету нацбезпеки я прошу поставити на
голосування
рекомендацію голові Верховної Ради
виконати рішення регламентного комітету
ваша пропозиція зрозуміла Ще раз говорю
порядок денний формується шляхом
погоджувальної ради але дуже дивно
стефанчук продовжує її захищати і він не
виніс цю Постанову на розгляд зали це
один я пам'ятаю як в цій залі не
одноразово під процедуру едхок включали
в порядок денний законопроекти і потім
їх голосували прямо ж в ці хвилини от
завжди Ми сподівалися що в цій Президії
подвійних стандартів не буде якщо зараз
починаються подвійні стандарти то ви так
чесно відверто і скажіть що ви стали не
з цієї ноги саме тому сьогодні стаття
третя в нас працює а наступного
засідання стаття третя ви включається
тому що ви встали з правої ноги Ну а
сама Маріана вона в якійсь худі з
драконами прибігла в наш сектор в сілася
отут от в цьому ряду не знаю може хоче в
європейську Солідарність але в нас таких
не приймають в першу чергу будь ласка
пані Мар'яни відійдуть від мене не треба
до мене підходити я тут цьому підтримую
бужанського змусьте колегу нашу яка тут
ходить по залу дотримуватися регламенту
і не перешкоджати іншим народним
депутатам виступати поведінка якась
неадекватна для політика і депутата ми
наближаємося до других руковин
повномасштабного вторгнення і очевидно
що пріоритетом для парламенту мають бути
законопроекти на захист збройних сил
України і підтримку нашої армії
принциповим є обов'язкове відзначення
десятків тисяч загиблих героїв солдатів
і офіцерів родини і побратими яких
запитують чому ті хто загинули як герої
не мають ордена і медалі в той час коли
бійці гумористичного фронту з 95-го
кварталу ві в орденах ми вимагаємо аби
тут нарешті з'явився уряд і відновилися
години запитань до уряду і це дуже
важливо для того аби ми усвідомлювали Що
Що Взагалі відбувається в уряді як він
збирається далі працювати Тому що
враження що сунака ми бачимо тут
прем'єр-міністра Британії частіше ніж
українського прем'єра
шмигаля година запитань до уряду остання
в парламенті була у вересні Минулого
року Вибачте два роки тому було
провалено підготовку до війни Так ми
зараз провалюємо оборону
і фортифікаційні споруди і нам немає
кому задати запитання А де 42 млрд на
200 000 Дронів де армія Дронів Ми хочемо
почути і Верховного головнокомандувача
позицію щодо того як він бачить от зміни
закону до мобілізації в першу чергу і
звичайно уряду і тому вважаємо що перед
тим як виносити в сесійну залу там
проекти таких серйозних законів потрібно
їх дуже серйозно пропрацювати
проговорити звичайно з військовими аби
комплексно ее розглядати ці
законопроекти Я прошу не вестись на ці
провокації та маніпуляції я розберуся
сам якось Ось таким був пленарний день
друзі підписуйтеся на наш YouTube канал
будьте з нами Тому що тут все про роботу
парламенту